[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen alles
Wichtige vom Sport kommt von Norbert
Lehmann einen schönen guten Abend auch
von mir als erstes schauen wir aber auf
die Hochwassergebiete
Überschwemmungen in Griechenland nach
schweren Unwettern spitzt sich die
Situation in vielen Gegenden weiter zu
Krise in der Bauwirtschaft Kreditzinsen
und Baukosten machen einer ganzen
Branche schwer zu schaffen
und vor dem WM Halbfinale gegen die USA
Deutschlands Basketballer hoffen auf die
große Überraschung
[Musik]
gewaltige Regenmengen haben die Lage in
Mittel Griechenland weiter verschlimmert
die Lage ist so dramatisch dass
Regierungschef Mittag ist das Militär in
Überschwemmungsgebiete geschickt hat
einige Dörfer sind quasi von der
Außenwelt abgeschnitten
unter schwierigsten Bedingungen müssen
griechische Helferinnen und Helfer
tausende Menschen aus den Fluten retten
viele konnten sie bis jetzt noch gar
nicht erreichen am schlimmsten betroffen
ist die Region Thessalien rund 700.000
Menschen leben Alexandra Vacano
berichtet
das Wasser ist inzwischen so viele Meter
hoch dass die Menschen auf die Dächer
ihrer Häuser flüchten und auf Hilfe
warten mussten hier in der Region cadiza
einer erzählt am Telefon im griechischen
Fernsehen dass er mit Einsatzkräften in
Kontakt war aber der Ort ist nicht
zugänglich die gesamte Ebene ist
überschwemmt sie haben uns gesagt dass
sie von Nirgendwo herankommen können
weder der Katastrophenschutz noch die
Armee die Moderatorin fragt nicht mal
mit einem Boot oder Hubschrauber
vielleicht mit einem Hubschrauber
antwortet er aber wo soll er landen es
gibt keine Landefläche
wegen des schlechten Wetters konnte das
Militär erst im Laufe des Tages die
ersten von ihren Dächern aus der Luft
retten
auch mit Booten lief ein großer Einsatz
so die Feuerwehr
Kostas Papa Jannis war am späten Abend
der letzte in seiner backwarenfabrik in
wollers um zu retten was nicht mehr zu
retten war wie er erzählt was soll ich
nur sagen so viel Wasser so viel
Zerstörung es ist unfassbar Gedanken den
Rettern dass sie uns geholfen haben da
lebend herauszukommen
Wasser wohin das Auge reicht in Mittel
Griechenland Brücken und Straßen sind
zerstört oder überflutet Dörfer von der
Außenwelt abgeschnitten nach drei Tagen
mit gewaltigen Regenmengen
alle Kräfte des Katastrophenschutzes der
Feuerwehr der Armee der Polizei und der
Küstenwache sind bis zur Selbstaufgabe
im Einsatz Treibgut erschwert den
Einsatz der Boote in anderen Fällen
lässt die reißende Kraft des Wassers
nicht zu sich anzunähern die heftigen
Blitze erlauben es nicht mit Flugzeugen
in die überschwemmten Gebiete
vorzudringen
inzwischen Lauf noch erste
Hilfslieferungen an die in wollos dort
geht das Trinkwasser aus und jetzt wo
der Regen langsam nachlässt wird das
große Ausmaß der Katastrophe sichtbar
ja riesige Wassermassen vor Ort ist für
uns Annette hilsenbeck Annette wie gehen
die Menschen damit um
ja zunächst mal ist es ja so dass die
Menschen zum Teil aus ihrem Dörfern
evakuiert also in Sicherheit gebracht
wurden denn die sind immer noch oftmals
hier in der Gegend rum Larissa von
Fluten überspielt
die Straßen sind immer noch nicht
umzugänglich deswegen hinter mir auch
diese Straßensperre und von daher ist
das für die Menschen extrem schwierig
die Menschen die bisher jetzt irgendwie
nach dem Regen Fällen in der Lage waren
wieder in ihre Häuser zurückzukehren in
ihre Dörfer versuchen zu retten was zu
retten ist wir haben heute einen
Getreidesilo besucht wo sie versucht
haben das rauszupumpen was noch trocken
ist und das ist nicht viel das heißt die
Hälfte mindestens das gesamten Getreide
Vorrat ist das gesamten Dorfes ist
zerstört durch die Fluten
wie groß diese Schäden insgesamt sein
werden das sagen die Menschen hier
werden Sie natürlich erst sehen wenn die
Fluten
zurückgeflossen sind wenn das Wasser
abgezogen ist aber hier in der
landwirtschaftlichen kahnkammer
Griechenlands sind diese Schäden in der
Landwirtschaft enorm groß danke nette
Hessen weg
zur deutschen Innenpolitik scharfe
Kritik der Opposition an Innenministerin
Feser denn sie hatte den Chef des
Bundesamtes für Sicherheit in der
Informationstechnik eine Schönbohm
abgesetzt wegen des Vorwurfs einer zu
großen Nähe zur Russland ins Rollen
gekommen war das Ganze durch einen
Bericht im ZDF-Magazin Royal wegen der
Versetzung sollte die Ministerin heute
in einer weiteren Sitzung des Bundestags
Innenausschusses Rede und Antwort stehen
phesa auch
spd-spitzenkandidatinnen in Hessen wo
bald gewählt wird kam nicht lass
Bohnsack
um ihn geht es Arne schönboom ehemaliger
Chef der cybersicherheit Innenministerin
Feser hatte ihn letztes Jahr abgesetzt
dabei soll sie so die Opposition den
eigenen Apparat aufgefordert haben
nachträglich nach belastendem Material
zu suchen steht dass er ernst der
Verdacht im Raum dass die
bundesinnenministerin Feser versucht hat
den
Verfassungsschutz den
Inlandsgeheimdienst zu
instrumentalisieren um eine Entscheidung
von ihr eine falsche Entscheidung von
ihr zu Entlassung bzw Versetzung des
Herrn Schönborn nachträglich
zurechtfertigen genährt wird der
Verdacht durch ein internen Vermerk
eines Mitarbeiters von Väter sie war
sichtlich unzufrieden sie fand die Dinge
die wir ihr zugeliefert haben zu dünn
wir sollten nochmals den
Bundesverfassungsschutz abfragen und
alle Geheimunterlagen zusammentragen
entscheidend ist nicht ob eine zweite
Abfrage stattfand sondern das Ansinnen
der Ministerin einen anderen Sachstand
zu bekommen als der der ihr tatsächlich
referiert wurde nachdem die
Innenministerin zum Ärger der Opposition
am Morgen nicht im Innenausschuss
erschienen war verwahrte sie sich am
Nachmittag im Bundestag gegen die
Vorwürfe in der Causa Schönborn
er hat selbst ein Disziplinarverfahren
gegen sich beantragt diese Prüfung
meines Ministeriums war gründlich und
das musste sie auch sein und um auch das
jetzt ohne jeden Zweifel klar zu sagen
dabei sind keine nachrichtendienstlichen
Maßnahmen gegen Herrn schönbum
eingesetzt worden diese Behauptung ist
völliger Unsinn meine Damen und Herren
zufrieden zeigt sich die Opposition
nicht mit dieser Aussage und erwegt
einen Untersuchungsausschuss zu
beantragen
im Bayerischen Landtag gab es heute eine
Sondersitzung zur flugblattaffäre grüne
SPD und FDP wollten vizem
Ministerpräsident Hubert eiwanger vor
den Freien Wählern direkt zu den
Antisemitismus Vorwürfen befragen er
äußerte sich jedoch nicht und auch
csu-ministerpräsident Söder schwieg in
Bayern wird in einem Monat gewählt über
die Sitzung berichtet Alexander Pool
schon am Morgen schien klar Hubert
Aiwanger wird sich in der heutigen
Landtagsdebatte nicht äußern für den
Chef der Freien Wähler ist die
flugblattaffäre abgeschlossen für die
Opposition noch lange nicht
sie kennen offenbar keine roten Linien
sie wiegeln Menschen auf um daraus
politischen Profit zu schlagen und das
ist für mich ein klares Kennzeichen für
Rechtspopulismus die Kritik an Bayern
stellvertretende Ministerpräsidenten
kommt heute nicht nur aus den Rhein der
Opposition
bemerkenswert deutlich auch der
Koalitionspartner CSU der wird Aiwanger
Feigheit vor
aufrecht mutig und direkt heraus sein
muss man nicht nur im Bierzelt Florian
Streibel der Fraktionschef der Freien
Wähler nimmt Hubert Aiwanger erneut den
Schutz wie Aiwanger übt auch Streibl
Kritik an den Medien und ihren
vermeintlichen Zeugen Hubert Aiwanger so
Streibl sei nicht derselbe wie vor 35
Jahren
und die Frage um die es hier geht lautet
ist Hubert ellwang ein Antisemit und die
Antwort auf diese Frage lautet eindeutig
nein und auch um ihn ging es heute
Markus Söder seine Entscheidung Hubert
Aiwanger im Amt zu belassen schade
Bayerns ansehen so die grüne und als
Ministerpräsident haben sie die Aufgabe
Schaden vom Land abzuwenden ich finde es
schade Herr Söder dass sie es nicht
geschafft haben Haltung zu zeigen
sondern sich für Taktik entschieden
haben die Mehrheit stimmte heute gegen
die Entlassung von Hubert Aiwanger aus
dem Kabinett
die ministerpräsidentinnen und
Präsidenten der Länder setzen sich für
strompreisssubventionen ein bei einem
Besuch in Brüssel forderten sie
geschlossen dass die EU vorübergehend
staatliche energiezuschüsse für
Unternehmen ermöglichen solle damit
wollen sie auch Druck auf die
Bundesregierung ausüben die sich noch
nicht auf ein Konzept zur
strompreisssubventionierung einigen
konnte
Regierung
Opposition Länder und Kommunen sollen in
einer gemeinsamen kraftanstrellung das
Land modernisieren dieser Vorschlag für
ein sogenannten Deutschland Pakt von
Kanzler Scholz stößt auf geteiltes Echo
die Arbeitgeber zeigten sich
grundsätzlich offen auch CDU-Chef März
sagte die Union sei bereit vernünftige
Vorschläge mitzumachen viele Fragen
seien aber noch nicht geklärt von altem
Wein in neuen Schläuchen sprach dagegen
der Städte und Gemeindebund
auch der Wohnungsbau soll laut Kanzler
schneller vorankommen aber gerade gehen
immer mehr Bauträger pleite und das
trifft gerade auch diejenigen die ihr
Erspartes und geliehenes in eine
Eigentumswohnung gesteckt haben und
jetzt nicht wissen ob sie jemals fertig
gebaut wird oder das Geld einfach weg
ist über das Problem berichtete
in diesem Rohbau mitten im Düsseldorfer
Zentrum waren Dutzende von Wohnungen
geplant stattdessen Stillstand auch bei
diesem Wohnprojekt wenige Kilometer
entfernt ruhen die Arbeiten der
Bauträger ist insolvent nicht nur
hunderte Käufer bangen jetzt um ihr Geld
auch Düsseldorfs planungsdezernentin
Cornelia zuske ist besorgt mehr als 500
Wohnungen stehen auf der Kippe mir macht
es große Kopfzerbrechen weil wir stehen
natürlich auch in den Prozessen draußen
bei den Menschen wir sehen wie die
Wohnungen gebraucht werden und von daher
ist das natürlich eine sehr sehr
schwierige Situation Baustopp und
Pleiten nicht nur in Düsseldorf ein
Problem in fast allen größeren Städten
drohen Bau Ruinen und brachen denn immer
mehr namhafte Projekte Entwickler melden
ihn insolvenzern Grund hohe Baukosten
und extrem hohe Zinsen die Pleitewelle
werde wohl noch größere Kreise ziehen
vermuten Experten wir haben einen
unglaublich kleinteiligen Markt mit rund
16.000 Bauträgern in Deutschland
und da sind einfach viele die von
einzelnen Projekten abhängen und da
werden wir noch mehr Insolvenzen erleben
für den ohnehin schon angespannten
Wohnungsmarkt ein Alarmsignal denn
allein im ersten Halbjahr 2023 sind
Wohnbauprojekte gegenüber dem
Vorjahreszeitraum um 54% zurückgegangen
derzeit fehlen über 700.000 Wohnungen am
deutschen Mietmarkt und das zeigt am
Ende auch die Konsequenz für ja den
sozialen Sprengstoff den es zweifelsfrei
gibt um das Wohnungsangebot künftig zu
stärken will die Stadt Düsseldorf heute
ein Maßnahmenpaket Schnüren dazu zählen
zum Beispiel Vorkaufsrechte für
unbebaute Grundstücke als auch Förderung
sozialer Wohnprojekte bauspekulanten
dürften ist damit sehr viel schwerer
haben
es sind schwerste Vorwürfe die von der
Menschenrechtsorganisation Human Rights
Watch gegen Saudi arabische grenzschütze
erhoben werden sie sollen an der Grenze
zum Jemen hunderte Migrantinnen und
Migranten darunter auch Kinder
erschossen haben
die Opfer sind aus Äthiopien Menschen
die in Saudi Arabien Arbeiten suchen die
meisten nehmen den Weg über die mehr
enge am hauen von Afrika und durch den
jungen einer Feist berichtet
ihre Reise in der Hoffnung auf ein
besseres Leben in Saudi-Arabien dauert
Wochen doch für viele äthiopia endet
dieser Traum hier im Jemen
said hat Granatsplitter abbekommen
wanna hat Schussverletzungen in Arm und
Bein
es waren bewaffnete saudische Soldaten
sie schossen mit Kugeln auf uns
mindestens 20 Patienten seien es
monatlich die hier mit schwersten
Verletzungen behandelt würden bestätigt
der Oberarzt
die Verletzungen zeigen die Menschen
wurden angegriffen ohne Abstand es sind
direkte Schüsse mit leichten und
schweren Waffen die Sau durch
chemietische Grenze hier soll es seit
Jahren systematisch zu schweren
Menschenrechtsverletzungen durch
saudische Grenzer kommen die saudische
Regierung aber dementiert das sie sagen
es seien militante Gruppen im
Grenzgebiet die auf die äthiopia
schießen würden
eine Lüge behauptet er habe bis Anfang
des Jahres für den saudischen
Geheimdienst gearbeitet sei auch an der
Grenze im Einsatz gewesen seit drei
Jahren gelte dort ein Befehl
im Jahr 2020 kam ein Tötungsbefehl von
Prinz Mohammed bin Salman persönlich der
Befehl heißt jeden Menschen zu töten der
in die Nähe kommt der saudischen Grenze
die Bundesregierung fordert Aufklärung
denn seit 2009 bilden deutsche
Bundespolizisten saudische Grenze aus
unterdessen finden wir auf diesem
jiminitischen Friedhof unweit der Grenze
eine neue Grabstelle für äthiopische
Migranten datiert auf Ende August
er war sowohl als Landes wie auch als
Bundespolitiker anerkannt der frühere
erste Bürgermeister von Hamburg
Hans-ulrich Klose ist im Alter von 86
Jahren gestorben der SPD-Politiker war
von 1974 bis 1981 Regierungschef in der
Hansestadt kurz darauf zog an den
Bundestag ein dem er 30 Jahre lang
angehörte Klose machte sich einen Namen
als Außenpolitiker und war
zwischenzeitlich auch
Fraktionsvorsitzender der SPD
schauen wir auf eine besondere
Ausstellung im Jüdischen Museum in
Berlin sie stellt die Frage wie lebten
jüdische Menschen in der DDR in einem
Staat der mit Israel keine Freundschaft
pflegte der Opfer des Faschismus zwar
Erde damit aber vor einem Kommunisten
meinte die Ausstellung gibt bekannten
und unbekannten jüdischen Menschen in
der DDR eine Stimme Zeugnisse einer noch
weitgehend unbeleuchteten deutschen
Geschichte Silvia blessmann
jüdisch sein spielte für Marion Brasch
nie eine Rolle als Antifaschisten
verstanden sich viele Juden in der DDR
meine Eltern waren ja bei dem Exil als
Juden und sind es Kommunisten
wiedergekommen und hatten die Idee von
einem anderen Deutschlands die
allermeisten die aus den Exil Ländern
zurückkehrten gingen in die Sowjetische
Besatzungszone darunter Prominente wie
Arnold Zweig oder einer säges die
Ausstellung zeigt wie Juden oft als SED
Mitglieder im neuen Stadt Verantwortung
übernommen es gab wirklich diese
Hoffnung um eine antifaschistische
Staats in Ostdeutschland aufzubauen und
die Hoffnung dass dort Religion
Antisemitismus und all diese Sachen
keine Rolle mehr spielt denn David Stern
offen besuchte auch ihre kleine jüdische
Gemeinde und doch verließ sie die DDR
auch jüdische Kultur und auch Religionen
leben wollte in einer Vielfalt die es an
der Form in der DDR trotz der jüdischen
Gemeinde nicht gab Prominente wie
Biermann oder Gysi sind Juden nach
stalinistischen Säuberungen verließen
vor allem Rabbiner das Land so dass es
kaum noch rituelles jüdisches Leben gab
es spielt überhaupt keine Rolle des
jüdische Leben also das jüdische auch
die jüdische Geschichte spielte keine
Rolle bei uns in der Familie also auch
im Alltag nicht die rote Assimilation
von Juden in den acht jüdischen
Gemeinden hat ihre Spuren hinterlassen
am Ende dieses anderen Landes gab es
zwar verordneten Antifaschismus aber
kaum Wissen über Juden
jetzt kommen wir zur Basketball WM
Norbert da heißt es ja morgen Mittag
Daumen drücken für Deutschland das erste
Mal seit 21 Jahren das ein dbb Team
wieder in einem WM Halbfinale steht ja
und dann auch noch gegen die USA die
sind klarer Favorit ein Sieg gegen den
fünfmaligen Weltmeister wäre schon eine
Sensation
der erzählt dass sie im Viertelfinale
ist kaum verarbeitet da wird
Deutschlands Basketball in der größte
Brocken vorgesetzt
die Spiele der USA reingezogen und unser
Viertelfinale kein feiern kein Wein kein
Bier
Turnier Favorit USA hat die Italiener im
Viertelfinale nach allen Regeln
auseinander genommen einige
zirkuseinlagen inklusive pflichtgemäß
das Lob des Trainers
Deutschland hat wohl das bisher beste
Team des Turniers die haben den Druck
wir haben das erreicht was wir machen
wollten und ähm im Endeffekt
können wir ohne Druck spielen wenn der
Teamkapitän seine schwache Leistung aus
dem Lettland Spiel vergessen macht dann
wird es im Halbfinale hoffentlich keine
Bruchlandung geben
Samstag Testspiel der DFB Männer gegen
Japan gestern durchaus kritische Worte
von BVB Verteidiger Niklas süle in
Richtung Bundestrainer heute
Unterstützung für Hansi fliegt durch
einen anderen großen Julian Brandt
das seit vier Spielen sieglose
flick-team will alle Kräfte mobilisieren
um die Ergebniskrise zu beenden den
unter Erfolgsdruck stehenden
Bundestrainer neben die Spieler sehr
fokussiert war hat er den letzten Wochen
Monaten glaube ich eine Menge auf die
Schnauze bekommen
[Musik]
ich finde der Macht sensationell
momentan er ist sehr klar in seinen
Ansprachen ich glaube auch dass er ganz
genau weiß was er möchte ohne den
verletzten muss ja leider heute wegen
Rückenproblem ab sagte soll die dringend
benötigte Wende her
das deutsche dressur-team mit
top-reiterin Jessica von Bredo Werndl
hat bei der Heim EM in Riesenbeck Silber
geholt Gold ging an Großbritannien zu
den US Open da ist Alexander Zverev im
Viertelfinale ausgeschieden der
Olympiasieger war gegen den
Weltranglisten ersten Carlos fast
chancenlos auch wegen einer Verletzung
am Oberschenkel und verloren drei Sätzen
klar mit 3 zu 6 2 6 4 zu
sehen aber Laura Siegemund hat es als
letzte deutsche immerhin ins
doppelhalbfinale geschafft
Aktionshaus geht es diese Woche ziemlich
ausgelassen so
es ist ein Fest für die Fans der Band
Queen hier
1.400 private Stücke von Freddie Mercury
kommen unter den Hammer sein legendärer
roter Umhang Sam Krone ging weg für
umgerechnet 740.000 Euro teuerste Stück
der Flügel auf dem er die meisten seiner
Songs komponierte 2 Millionen Euro
das sonnige und warme Spätsommerwetter
hält noch einige Tage an mehr dazu
gleich von Katja horneffer das heute
journal können Sie heute schon um 21:40
sehen mit Marietta Slomka auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend auch in den vergangenen 24
Stunden hat es in Griechenland noch
kräftig geregnet und selbst nachts
entwickelten sich über dem warmen
Mittelmeerwasser weitere Gewitter sonst
dominiert ja über Europa ein hoch und
lenkt die ganzen Wolken muss sich herum
und auf nächtlichen Satellitenbildern
sehen wir sehr gut die
Lichtverschmutzung hier zum Beispiel in
der Poebene aber auch die Küsten
zeichnen sich ab auch große Städte wie
Madrid oder Paris wie Hamburg oder
Berlin sogar das Nil Delta in Ägypten
kann sie sehen interessant sind zur Zeit
auch die Temperaturen deutschlandweit
sind die höchsten Temperaturen ja oft am
Oberrhein zu erwarten nicht so heute da
gab es die höchsten Temperaturen mit 32
Grad in Duisburg und das lag an einem
kleinen Föhneffekt aus dem Sauerland
heute Nacht sinken die Werte auf 18 Grad
an der Nordsee bis 9 Grad in Bayern
meistens der Himmel klar erst zum frühen
Morgen bildet sich im Süden vielleicht
mal etwas Nebel und auch morgens wieder
viel Sonnenschein bei Südostwind und
Sommer für alle also Sommertemperaturen
zwischen 26 Grad am alten Rand und 32
Grad westlich das eins und genau so geht
es bis Anfang der kommenden Woche weiter
guten Abend